[主播] 需要培养的一种能力啊。大家后来发现董宇辉把任何食物都赋予了过多的意义。
[主播] 这是一种本能，就是我尝试从平淡生活里头去拔掉原有的刺，然后呢尝试给平淡的生活赋予它更加丰富的意义。
[主播] 日子都是一天一天过的，你不可能每天都浪迹天涯，也不可能每天都
[主播] 呃，仗剑四方，对吧？所以呢，虽然日子平淡，但是只要你内心有美，你看到的全是风景。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 感谢大家啊。
[主播] 大家现在不要跟我说了，那个词是用来夸石明老师的。
[主播] 你们再这样，再这样我就伤害自己，让你心疼。
[主播] 呃，除了这个南瓜以外还有什么，导演？
[主播] 这个南瓜今天有多少单？
[嘉宾] 还有香菇。
[嘉宾] 今天还有8000单。
[主播] 还有8000单。
[主播] 终于有个可以顶著扛卖的农产品了。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 我记得去年冬天我们一开始卖这个小南瓜的时候，那会我还跟石明老师合租啊，然后我当时每天早上起来，就是人生中最难的那一段时间。
[主播] 坦诚来说，从工作这么多年来最难的一段时间，就是2000块钱生活费，然后要过一个月的时候，还要缴这个话费、电费、水费的时候。
[主播] 我当时就买了这个Baby Pumpkin,因为我们直播间里在卖。
[主播] 然后就是你生活有难的时候，其实你也要学会去珍惜自己，照顾自己。
[主播] 你你一定会一个人独行过一段特别黑的时间，就犹如一个长长的隧道一样。
[主播] 你你可能很长时间看不到光，你有的时候觉得要不我就放弃吧，我就躺这吧。
[主播] 我要回家，我要找爸妈，我要哭，我要诉苦。
[主播] 我应该有诉苦的权利，对吗？
[主播] 其实你再走一走，前面就有了微微的光亮了。
[主播] 我我当时就，因为我那段时间就心情不太好，坦诚来说生活状态也不太好，所以我当时就尝试给自己一些这种正向的鼓励。
[主播] 我平常是一个生活能力非常低的人，生活能力非常低的人。
[主播] 所以我那段尝试给自己一些正向的暗示。
[主播] 所以呢，当时就买了一个这个，买了一份我们直播间的这个Baby南瓜。
[主播] 然后呢，把它洗干净，早上等我去冲澡的时候，放在那个煮蛋的那个小锅里头，上面有个小的那个人梯，可能就八分钟左右。
[主播] 等我冲澡出来了，然后收拾好了，他也蒸好了。
[主播] 我就拿个小盒子，还记得去年冬天一段时间。
[主播] 每天拿个小盒子，一个小盒子里头是煮的两个鸡蛋。
[主播] 一个小盒子是南瓜。
[嘉宾] 再喝点牛奶。
[主播] 啊对，对。
[主播] 牛奶一般要从公司偷，要从公司借。
[主播] 一般要从公司借，牛奶太贵了。
[嘉宾] 理解。
[主播] 牛奶一般太贵了，我当时是，当时是这个喝不起牛奶的。
[主播] 一般就趁著大家不注意，来到我们直播间，看一下那个架子上的牛奶没有展示完的。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 借喝一下，以后会还的。
[主播] 会还的，欠你都会还的。
[嘉宾] 因为喝了好喝才给你借嘛。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 所以，所以，我我我现在一想到南瓜就想到了去年冬天。
[主播] 想到了我们首秀之后铺天盖地对我们来批评的声音。
[主播] 想到那段时间好像就我们几个抱团取暖。
[主播] 想到了我们虽然内心很柔软，但外面坚硬的像这个南瓜一样，其实内心全是
[主播] 有时候是空洞的，对吧？是空洞的，你看不懂方，你那个男男也感觉到很真实。
[主播] 我记得那段时间就自己鼓励，下班骑个自行车。
[主播] 从这骑到人大西门。
[主播] 就是从中关村骑到人大西门。
[主播] 一路车上就晃荡晃荡晃荡，然后听许威给自己力量。
[主播] 早上起来呢，蒸个背南瓜。
[主播] 所以背南瓜可以成为一个非常好吃，方便，而且暖心的早餐。
[主播] 赋予食物意义，给生活找到美感。
[主播] 热爱生活，健康早餐。
[主播] 各位朋友们，大家想要自己去拍啊。
[主播] 谢谢大家。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 这个是有灵魂的南瓜，也不一定。
[主播] 南瓜其实没有灵魂，食物其实很普通。
[主播] 这个南瓜跟世界上千万个南瓜是一样的。
[主播] 不小王子的原句嘛，对吧？
[主播] It is the rose you wasted, it is the time you wasted for the rose that makes the rose so important.
[主播] 其实很多时候你会回想，你交过很多朋友，对吧？虽然有一天你这个好像全世界人都在找你的时候。
[主播] 但是你还是愿意晚上回去跟你以前那些特别艰难时期，然后呢，那些难熬的夜里，你们俩愿意促膝长谈，推心换展，互相鼓励的那些好朋友，打电话聊一个小时。
[主播] 就是
[主播] 你得记住难的时候是什么支撑著你向前。
[主播] 那个很重要。
[主播] 那个经常是你的精神动力。
[主播] 大家很难相信董宇辉的人生是有多么枯燥，就连一份南瓜都可以成为他的人生动力。
[主播] 差不多吧，差不多。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 南瓜这个卖的差不多了，今天这个李白传有多少本？
[嘉宾] 李白传。
[主播] 我得给大家说一下，关于李白传其实有很多种不同的版本。
[主播] 然后大家可能平常读的多的事是李长之先生写的那个。
[嘉宾] 5万本。
[主播] 这个是安琪写的。
[主播] 安琪写的这个呢，
[主播] 它故事性更好一些。
[主播] 它可能往往以一个真正人的视角。
[主播] 好像你陪伴一个朋友去看著他的一生一样。
[主播] 我觉得这个其实对于大本读者读起来来说，其实也很适合，也很适合。
[主播] 我自己认真把这本书看了一遍。
[主播] 我觉得很写的也很好。
[主播] 它的文笔很简单，然后呢，却很有这种生活化的气息。
[主播] 这里头写到了很多关于李白的什么，这个如果你有你直接上好吗？
[嘉宾] 已经上了。
[主播] 然后人接。
[主播] 我们在每次想到苏东坡的时候，想到了一个天生乐观，然后虽然生活屡次遇到逆境，但总是能够调整心态，发现生命中美好的一个好朋友。
[主播] 我们隐隐约约中的苏东坡是充满著智慧的。
[主播] 智慧就是面对人生的困境的时候不沮丧，面对人生挫折的时候不消沉。
[主播] 智慧就是在生命大的课题，跟人生小的惊喜之间学会做选择。
[主播] 你无法决定你被贬黄州、惠州还是丹州，但是你可以选择吃东坡肉，吃荔枝还是吃生蚝。
[主播] 所以我们提到了苏东坡，其实提到了一个智慧的人。
[主播] 他像一个我们身边都喜欢的一个朋友一样。
[主播] 我们提到了杜甫的时候，提到了一个忧郁的诗人，他落魄，他不得志。
[主播] 虽然自己日子过得很苦，但是他总想著别人，就像用现在流行话说。
[主播] 因为自己淋过雨，所以总想著为别人撑伞。
[主播] 我们每次在读到杜甫的诗的时候，都感觉到这个人年轻时候经历的一点点的好日子，就年轻时候经历的一点点灿烂，真的是用后半生的寂寞来全部偿还。
[主播] 这句话好像是江谬的，是吧？
[主播] 年轻时候经历的灿烂，用一生来偿还。
[主播] 不是。
[主播] 不是傻，对不起，我忘了，忘了啊。
[主播] 忘了，对不起。
[主播] 应该不是江谬，不是江谬，我说错了，不是江谬。
[主播] 呃，杜甫年轻的时候，因为他父亲在当县令，他在河南巩义出生。
[主播] 父亲当县令，对吧？然后呢，小时候养在姑姑家。
[主播] 姑姑为了照顾他呢，姑姑的儿子生病之后，姑姑把所有的精力照顾他，姑姑家的儿子都病死了。
[主播] 所以杜甫从小就是在人的偏爱下长大。
[主播] 然后很小就遇见公孙大娘舞剑。
[主播] 公孙大娘可是当时名扬天下的人。
[主播] 杜甫考了三次高考也没考上，对吧？去山东玩。
[主播] 然后呢，
[主播] 会当临绝顶，一览众山小。
[主播] 但晚年我们也知道他在颠沛流离中，对吧？在成都因为有严武的保护。
[主播] 在成都待了四到五年。
[主播] 后来去夔州，别人给了一些果园。
[主播] 在夔州写了登高。
[主播] 我们后来再看杜甫的时候，他一路在逃难逃难，逃到湖南。
[主播] 对吧？然后因为水涨船高，没地方，没东西吃，说饿了四五天。
[主播] 还好后来县令送来东西，要不然得饿死。
[主播] 我们后来在听杜甫的时候，就像家里那个过得不怎么顺心的孩子一样，对他充满忧虑，也对他的人生充满了怜悯和同情。
[主播] 他是一个如此有家国情怀的人，他在生活中的情感也是非常的细腻。
[主播] 他连自己都过得那么惨的时候，他也能想到说安得广厦千万间，大庇天下寒士俱欢颜。
[主播] 我们爱杜甫。
[主播] 我们爱杜甫就像爱自己家里混得不怎么好，但是心地善良，虽然落魄，但是不改自己气节的孩子一样。
[主播] 对不起，请抱歉，我用了孩子这两个词来形容他。
[主播] 因为读到杜甫的时候，对他的偏爱，我感觉真的像父母对于子女的偏爱一样。
[主播] 只是希望他好。
[主播] 哪怕希望他少受点苦，少写一点那种好的诗，但是希望他当时能过得顺遂一些都行。
[主播] 但是如果我们说到了李白，大家第一个反应其实是浪漫。
[主播] 我小时候听老师讲课，我们总在纸上写下了李白是浪漫主义诗人。
[主播] 李白是诗仙。
[主播] 李白秀口一吐，就是半个盛唐。
[主播] 我们小时候对于李白总觉得这是一个家境优渥，一生呢也朋友众多，受到很多人的阶级，喝酒，吃肉，寻仙访药。
[主播] 十步杀一人，千里不留名。
[主播] 我们年轻时候听李白就是他是一个浪漫主义诗人，他浪漫的就像掉落人间的仙子一样。
[主播] 他像繁星点点的夜空中闪亮的那一颗一样。
[主播] 以至于人们就羡慕他的创作的能力，说如果能重来，我要当李白。
[主播] 我们喜欢那个让高力士给他脱靴子，让杨贵妃给他研墨，然后就看著人群中婷婷玉立的杨杨贵妃，然后脱口而出这个
[主播] 就能写出清平调的人。
[主播] 呃，云想衣裳花想容，春风拂槛露华浓。
[主播] 这是我们初读李白。
[主播] 长大了之后我再读李白，我觉得李白其实是给了我勇气。
[主播] 我刚说了苏东坡是智慧。
[主播] 我刚说了杜甫是悲悯。
[主播] 我觉得李白能给我智慧，给我勇气。
[主播] 智慧，悲悯和勇气。
[主播] 我觉得如果一个人同时具备了这三个东西，
[主播] 他应该是一个很受人喜欢，很很受人尊敬的人。
[主播] 我我我后来读李白读的越多，我越能感受到这些。
[主播] 有多少人能够接受自己一生壮志未酬啊？
[主播] 有多少人能够接受自己一生虽拼尽全力，但碌碌无为啊？
[主播] 有多少人能接受自己满腹才华，但不被赏识啊？
[主播] 有多少人能接受自己好友变天下，但无人知我心啊？
[主播] 崇拜你的人有很多，有人追了三千里去找你。
[主播] 你从皇宫出来之后，在洛阳见到了杜甫。
[主播] 短短相处，他用了十几年来回忆你。
[主播] 但他们不懂你。
[主播] 他们也担心你，对吧？你跟永王去造反了。
[主播] 你本来以为永王是真的赏识你，你觉得自己终于在人生的那个时间等来了一个赏识你的人，可以施展你内心的抱负的时候。
[主播] 结果永王后来判乱被平反了，永王被杀头了。
[主播] 你被关到了监狱里。
[主播] 而且当时关在监狱里痛苦的时候，负责关你的人其实是你当年好朋友叫岑参，大家都知道吧？
[主播] 边塞诗人岑参。
[主播] 你的妻子反复去求情。
[主播] 但他也没有救你。
[主播] 要不是后来大赦天下，在途中重获自由。
[主播] 你可能就惨死在流放路上了。
[主播] 释放之后，李白好像突然想通了。
[主播] 朝辞白帝彩云间。
[主播] 千里江陵一日还。
[主播] 两岸猿声啼不住，轻舟已过万重山。
[主播] 他一生
[主播] 娶过好几个女子，我们现在开玩笑说李白是最强赘婿。
[主播] 说羡慕他的运气。
[主播] 啊，说这个
[主播] 有多少人能够有他那样的机遇，能够遇到那样好的机会啊？
[主播] 但是那些人不懂李白。
[主播] 那些人但凡懂李白，李白也不会在30多岁，快40岁，会跟妻子吵架的时候说，仰天大笑出门去，我辈岂是蓬蒿人。
[主播] 难的不是别人不懂你，难的是你不懂自己。
[主播] 李白当时其实应该也挺难，因为他爱的人都不懂他。
[主播] 他爱的人都不欣赏他。
[主播] 我在想他心里应该很难吧。
[主播] 那种情况其实有很多的。
[主播] 我相信身边可能也有其他的人，可能也会有同样的生命经历，就是
[主播] 我刚说他妻子说你可能没有共鸣啊。
[主播] 但如果你所坚持的事情，你爸妈不理解呢？
[主播] 如果你所信奉的原则，周围的人在嘲讽呢？
[主播] 如果你所坚守的事业在别人看来不可能成功呢？
[主播] 你还有勇气去说仰天大笑出门去，我辈岂是蓬蒿人吗？
[主播] 有吗？
[主播] 很难了。
[主播] 你一生都在追寻，追寻一个赏识你的人。
[主播] 他能给你机会，施展你的才华。
[主播] 你仿佛一生也在追寻，追寻一个真正懂你的人，他能爱你，陪伴你。
[主播] 寻而不的。
[主播] 人生很多的时候遗憾就是这，人生的遗憾就是求之不得啊。
[主播] 所以晚年他仿佛对俗事已经没太有，没有太大的运气了。
[主播] 没有太大的期待了，小的时候想要，没有。
[主播] 后来有了，我也不想要了。
[主播] 所以才会写出独坐敬亭山。
[主播] 我在读到最后读作敬亭山的时候，我突然感觉到李白一生的这个心情的变化。
[主播] 当然呢，后人在谈李白的时候，总是充满了一种丰富的联想。
[主播] 大家总是在想著李白一生是如何的这个幸运，因为他生活在盛唐时期。
[主播] 李白是701年出生。
[主播] 701年跟王，王维同一年，他应该是76,762年。
[主播] 没记错的话，应该是762年去世的。
[主播] 活了62,活了61岁。
[主播] 在现在来看不算高龄。
[主播] 就连李白的去世也有好几种。
[主播] 第一种人们说他是醉死的。
[主播] 喝酒喝多了。
[主播] 你看他一喝酒，对吧？会需饮300杯啊。
[主播] 曾夫子单秋生，杯莫停。
[主播] 酒杯放下了，压鱼呢，喝。
[主播] 喝起来。
[主播] 人生苦短。
[主播] 赶快喝。
[主播] 往开了喝。
[主播] 李白好像总是逮著朋友喝酒，往翻了喝的那个人。
[主播] 大家也不知道为什么你酒量这么大，酒瘾这么大。
[主播] 也不知道你是真的快乐，还是借酒浇愁。
[主播] 他说了，借酒浇愁愁更愁，对吧？
[主播] 抽刀断水水更流啊。
[主播] 然后呢，
[主播] 第二种说法是很浪漫啊。
[主播] 说李白是这个上阵杀敌去的。
[主播] 他最后要替国出征。
[主播] 就像我们看到琅琊榜那个结局一样。
[主播] 他给了一个英雄体面。
[主播] 他让一个英雄以英雄主义的方式结束了他的一生。
[主播] 这是第二种传闻啊。
[主播] 第三种是逆死的。
[主播] 喝醉了。
[主播] 去水里捞月亮，淹死了。
[主播] 无从考证。
[主播] 但我们总喜欢给一个浪漫的人诸多的结局。
[主播] 我们希望他能从在那些结局中找到自己喜欢的一个。
[主播] 年少时不懂李白。
[主播] 长大时当不了李白。
[主播] 愿你我出走半生，归来仍是少年，少年之心，磅礴之气。
[主播] 虽经历苦难，但三观不改，虽变长黑暗，但初心坚定。
[主播] 大家可以把这句话打在屏幕去叫长变黑暗，三观不改。
[主播] 我觉得这就是我后来读李白的一个内心的变化。
[主播] 可能跟年少时期我读李白确实不一样的。
[主播] 年少时期只感觉到他的浪漫，黄河之水天上来，奔流到海不复回。
[主播] 什么样的人会写出这样东西？
[主播] 大鹏一日同风起，扶摇直上九万里。
[主播] 一张嘴都是天上来，都是九万里。
[主播] 只有李白敢说出这么大的话。
[主播] 小时候觉得他就是浪漫，觉得他不接地气。
[主播] 觉得他像一个泡的朋友，整天喝酒玩，喝酒玩。
[主播] 追求自由的星辰大海，长大之后才发现他其实是一个有勇气的人。
[主播] 长变黑暗，但三观不改。
[主播] 嗯，我可能说的不一定对啊。
[主播] 我可能说的不一定好。
[主播] 也欢迎大家这个能够在这个书里头找到自己
[主播] 认同的东西。
[主播] 也希望大家能够通过李白这个人找到自己对于勇气，对于豪迈，对于浪漫，对于诗自己的理解。
[主播] 因为我毕竟是个语文老师。
[主播] 可能屏幕前有很多语文老师，我相信大家会比我讲的更好。
[主播] 我相信，我相信。
[主播] 我相信，我在看一个诗人的时候，我我喜欢听很多的语文老师去讲他的生平，因为他们会说的更准确，甚至会说出哪一年在什么地方写了什么样的诗，当时是受了什么样的委屈。
[主播] 表达了什么样的情感，我相信你们会说的更专业。
[主播] 我只是一个比较不太专业的一个读者的角度，给大家稍微解读了一下。
[主播] 然后呢，也强烈的呼吁大家在拿到书之后自己赶快自己去读。
[主播] 最好再看一些关于他的纪录片，背下他的诗。
[主播] 我们去感受那个秀口一吐便是半个盛唐的人，他一生所经历的蒙昧、动荡、黑暗之后，仍然心智坚定。
[主播] 三观不改的事情。
[主播] 我年少时读浪漫，我长大之后读到勇气。
[主播] 可能是缺什么，人就读到了什么。
[主播] 所以读书的一个意义是什么？读书的一个意义就是在书里头找到你自己。
[主播] 你缺什么，你就读到了什么。
[主播] 嗯，这个还有吗？
[嘉宾] 已经卖了7000多本了。
[主播] 卖了7000多本是吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我觉得这个挺好的啊。
[嘉宾] 好不容易加的库存。
[主播] 好不容易加的库存，咱一共多少库存？
[嘉宾] 2万。
[主播] 2万，那很快就完了，今天直播间里20多万人呢。
[主播] 然后有朋友说这个东西会你再别胡说八道了。
[主播] 有可能说的确实不对。
[主播] 欢迎批评啊，欢迎批评。
[主播] 有可能我确实没有您说的专业。
[主播] 鼓励阅读总是对的。
[主播] 晚辈不才啊。
[主播] 若批评不自由。
[主播] 有可能我确实没有您说的专业。
[主播] 鼓励阅读总是对的。
[主播] 完毕不才啊。
[主播] 如果批评不自由，则赞美无意义，可以批评啊。
[主播] 作者叫安琪。
[主播] 下面这句话叫天子呼来不上船。
[主播] 自称城市九中仙。
[主播] 这一句诗其实不是李白写的。
[主播] 这句是杜甫写的。
[主播] 杜甫在写李白写了这句诗，叫天子呼来不上船。
[主播] 自称城市九中仙。
[主播] 其实这句话就是这个是人民文学出版社，所以请大家放心，这个校对什么的应该是很准确的。
[主播] 这个其实就是讲到了李白终于。
[主播] 李白应该是在谁的引荐下？
[主播] 孟浩然？
[主播] 在谁的引荐下？
[主播] 不是，在孟浩然引荐下娶了第一个媳妇。
[主播] 他第一个媳妇是经孟浩然介绍认识的。
[主播] 他在皇宫里，其实他以为自己可以大展红图。
[主播] 结果皇上马叫进去，只是让他每天写歌词。
[主播] 只是贺之章，对对对对，谢谢谢谢。
[主播] 贺之章，经贺之章的介绍，他其实终于有了一个入宫的机会。
[主播] 然后他也以为自己能够大展红图，结果进去之后就是让他写歌词。
[主播] 就我一身武艺，你却让我在这里给你做那些耍杂技的事情。
[主播] 李白不开心，每天把自己灌的烂醉。
[主播] 然后呢，让他写歌词。
[主播] 他写的歌词，然后这个李龟年去唱。
[主播] 你你说他能开心吗？
[主播] 我一身武艺，百步穿杨，你却让我在这里陪你玩老鹰捉小鸡。
[主播] 我无仗可打。
[主播] 我无计可施。
[主播] 我觉得刚这句话说的非常的真实，就是我空有一身武艺。
[主播] 我能百步穿杨。
[主播] 你却让我在这里陪你玩老鹰捉小鸡。
[主播] 我能开心就怪了。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 你让我写歌词不去。
[主播] 喝醉了，去不了，对不起。
[主播] 请假，我休年假了，对不起。
[主播] 休年假了是吧，喝醉了，那醉著写。
[主播] 不行，我脚疼。
[主播] 你让太过把鞋脱了。
[主播] 鞋脱了。
[主播] 我没有墨水，让杨贵妃给我磨墨。
[主播] 磨了。
[主播] 我们看到了一个像孩子一样的人。
[主播] 他其实是在跟自己自己生气。
[主播] 他跟自己生气。
[主播] 他想，他想实现内心的抱负。
[主播] 李白传。
[主播] 愿每一个人在李白传中找到属于自己少年时的勇气，怀著勇气。
[主播] 坚定的一直走下去。
[主播] 长变黑暗，但三观不改。
[主播] 历经苦难，但初心坚定。
[主播] 我希望我们能那样，但坦诚来说我们其实做不到的。
[主播] 我们做不到的。
[主播] 只有不到一万本。
[主播] 把这样的好书多卖几万本，真的是我们的福气。
[其他] 好书值得买。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 咱再看一下还有其他诗人的那种传记，也找一找。
[其他] 我们努力。
[主播] 对，然后呢，我昨天我给大家，我不知道我能让大家看一个照片吗？
[主播] 昨天晚上我看到有朋友跟我发的，他已经开始阅读了，我很开心。
[主播] 他的孩子。
[主播] 他说，他说他的孩子这两天听我在这直播完了之后，也听了elephant的故事。
[主播] 单词写的胳膊上。
[主播] 当然这个我不推荐啊，因为大家可能不一定非要学一个特别笨的人去飞。
[主播] 你明明可以更优雅的，你没有必要学我。
[主播] 然后还有一个朋友，我这个我把孩子的脸挡著。
[主播] 不能展示是吧？
[主播] 这个人说他带著孩子在西安旅行，开著车，孩子在车上在背这个我们买的美的窒息的唐诗宋词。
[主播] 还给我展示了孩子写的这个笔记。
[主播] 你看孩子写的这个字。
[主播] 看，写的白居义。
[主播] 白居义他是一个这个河南的诗人。
[主播] 孤山寺北甲亭西。
[主播] 水面出平云脚低。
[主播] 几处早鹰争暖树，谁家新燕著春泥。
[主播] 他写的这个表面的表子。
[主播] 然后带著孩子在西安玩呢。
[主播] 拍的视频孩子坐在车的后排。
[主播] 男孩被古诗。
[主播] 然后呢，家里的这个女儿呢，就被那个英语翻译。
[主播] 真好。
[主播] 这种就比较建议啊。
[主播] 当然呢，我这两天还说到很多孩子私信骂我。
[主播] 董老师，我们现在学校期末考试全是你的题，出的全是你。
[其他] 对。
[主播] 有孩子上大学说他们学校后面两那个大论述题写的全是我。
[主播] 第一个是从美的角度去欣赏，去分析这个我们不是卖大米吗？
[主播] 第二是从什么广告学的角度去尝试去理解什么跟顾客建立情感联系什么什么的。
[主播] 我说你们真专业。
[主播] 我都没想那么多。
[主播] 想到以前不是有个段子吗，高考中一个人写的作文，他写的文章说于蓝色的眼睛。
[主播] 然后把它放到高考作文让大家解析为什么是蓝色的眼睛。
[主播] 结果作者亲自说，因为鱼的眼睛就是蓝色的。
[主播] 作者可能也没想那么多。
[主播] 我们总是喜欢从很多东西中过度的解读，这是正常的。
[主播] 因为我们喜欢比他们感受的更加丰富一些。
[主播] 李白传。
[主播] 我不太专业，我应该改天请一个我们的语文老师来给大家再专业的讲一讲。
[其他] 还有7000本。
[主播] 还有7000本，我相信找一个语文老师专业的讲一讲，大家应该会对李白的感触更深刻一些。
[主播] 小时候被李白都是在自己的本子上写大鹏一日同风起，扶摇直上九万里。
[主播] 都是在本子上写。
[主播] 仰天大笑出门去，我被骑士彭浩然。
[主播] 都是写那些。
[主播] 给自己写力量感。
[主播] 写憧憬。
[主播] 写对于未来的期待，写一个少年之心。
[主播] 写一份内心坚定。
[主播] 你后来长大之后听了他很多的故事，感觉到他怀才不遇之后。
[主播] 我们也在长大，我们也在职场，我们也在工作。
[主播] 我们也会交朋友。
[主播] 我们也时常会遇到一些自己内心的想法没有被认可，自己的价值没有被肯定，甚至经常被周围亲密的人，甚至是家人怀疑的时候。
[主播] 我再回去感受他的事，我感受到的是真的属于一个强者内心的勇气。
[主播] 有多少个读者就可以多少个哈姆雷特。
[主播] 有多少本，有多少个读者就可以有多少种李白。
[主播] 基本的历史事实你必须要尊重。
[主播] 但是关于一首诗，你完全可以产生自己的理解。
[主播] 如果说，就是我之前所说的。
[主播] 如果世界上只剩下种美，那便没有了美。
[主播] 如果世界上只剩一种对，那压根就没有对。
[主播] 如果世界上只剩了成绩，那便没有了孩子，如果世界上只剩了金钱。
[主播] 只剩了物质，那可能也便没有了爱情。
[主播] 所以如果世界上只剩一种对于李白的解读。
[主播] 那就没有了李白。
[主播] 那读书还有什么意义？
[主播] 十万个人拿著同一本书。
[主播] 说出十万，十万句一模一样的话。
[主播] 十万个相同的大脑。
[主播] 那人的思考和这个批判能力在哪里？
[主播] 所以 think different, be brave to be different,OK?
[主播] 你可以产生自己的理解啊。
[主播] 李白传讲到这。
[主播] 下一个是李白传还有多少本？
[主播] 提醒大家，5000本是吧？
[主播] 好。
[其他] 我们家里还有7000本。
[主播] 有朋友说李白不是刺客吗？
[主播] 李白是刺客。
[其他] 王者荣耀的游戏里面是刺客。
[主播] 啊，是个游戏。
[其他] 对对对。
[其他] 这这不能说。
[主播] 很难过。
[主播] 我这讲了半天你告诉我是个刺客。
[主播] 我觉得这可能就是代沟了吧。
[其他] 现在。
[主播] 我我不玩任何游戏。
[主播] 当然当年高中的时候跟一群同学去网吧里还玩过那个什么飞车那类。
[主播] 后来再也没有玩过。
[主播] 对不起，我没理解你的意思啊。
[主播] 李白确实是武国剑的。
[主播] 嗯，但他的剑主要是表演性质居多，所以他写这个十步杀一人，千里不留名。
[主播] 他有可能杀过人，有可能。
[主播] 但你要说专业的武艺或者专业的剑术的话。
[主播] 那有待商榷。
[主播] 对不起，这就是我们俩之间的这个代沟吧，你说李白刺客我没反应过来。
[主播] 我如果说我的孩子有一天长大，一提到李白说他是个刺客，我应该还挺难过的吧。
[主播] 我觉得这么有意思一个历史上的名人，孩子却只觉得他是个刺客。
[主播] 来，香菇啊，香菇。
[主播] 对不起啊，对不起，我是个老师，我可能多嘴了。
[主播] 我只是自己有一点难受而已啊。
[主播] 别告诉我，他是刺客啊。
[主播] 谢谢谢谢。
[主播] 来。
[主播] 还有五香鸡。
[主播] 五香鸡啊。
[主播] 五香鸡的价格仍然是59块9两只对吧？
[主播] 59块9两只。
[主播] 这个五香鸡的口感特别好。
[主播] 我去年还是前年。
[其他] 16块。
[其他] 可以吃，汤汁。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 我去年去山东聊城去过一次讲座。
[主播] 还去临清。
[主播] 那个是季县林季老先生的老家。
[主播] 然后我我在那会去一个县城叫阳谷县，就是武松打虎那个地方，阳谷，武二郎。
[主播] 然后我记得我去当地去演讲完了之后，当地老师们去招待我们吃饭。
[主播] 山东人真的好爽。
[主播] 菜的份量都特别大。
[主播] 包括我们前段时间去这个青岛，我们自己做的榴莲去榴莲工厂去看生产线。
[主播] 晚上有一去吃饭。
[主播] 饭的菜的份量都特别大。
[主播] 我爱山东。
[主播] 然后呢，我们当时吃完饭在阳谷县吃完饭之后，那个老师就给我们包了几只烧鸡。
[主播] 就是那种侠客的感觉，好像喝了这杯酒，吃完这只烧鸡。
[主播] 我们就要远走天涯一样。
[主播] 挺喜欢那种文化和那种豪迈气的。
[主播] 五香鸡，这个是德州 Texas。
[主播] 不是不是美国的 Texas,是山东德州。
[主播] 喜欢吃的朋友可以拍一下啊。
[主播] 有朋友说你就是阳谷的是吧？
[主播] 我有是山东潍坊人。
[主播] 烧鸡其实很多地方都有，你比如说河南有道口烧鸡。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 然后其实陕西也有啊。
[主播] 就是每个地方应该对每个地方属于不同的一种卤味。
[主播] 这种卤味其实就体现了人们在生活中寻找的一些小惬意。
[主播] 呃，可能你忙了一天。
[主播] 可能你今天在单位里没有特别多开心的事情。
[主播] 可能你最近生活里也有一些鸡零狗碎。
[主播] 可能 very possible。
[主播] 但你知道有时候男人的快乐很简单。
[主播] 回到家里打开一只烧鸡。
[主播] 一个人趴在阳台上。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 他其实有时候不需要你跟他说话的。
[主播] 你如果愿意，其实你就坐在旁边陪他就行。
[主播] 你不用说话。
[主播] 他就默默的一个人趴在阳台上，吃一只烧鸡，喝点小酒。
[主播] 吹吹风，然后看一看这个万家灯火，或者远处马路上的这个人来人往，车流涌动。
[主播] 有时候很多成年男性的情绪其实都是自己消化。
[主播] 但是他消化时候得需要一些什么这个烧鸭呀，烧鸡啊，卤牛肉啊。
[主播] 最好再加一点点小酒。
[主播] 我后来也特别喜欢这种生活节奏。
[主播] 特别像一个。
[主播] 我不能说我像一个老年人。
[主播] 但我觉得这个很好，我很喜欢。
[主播] 很接地气。
[主播] OK。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 有朋友说有人在后面偷东西。
[主播] 那个不是偷东西，那个是我们所放的。
[主播] 很多的样品啊。
[主播] 你在桥上看风景。
[主播] 我在看你。
[主播] 我嘴里吃著烧鸡。
[主播] 你有没有兴趣跟我来一起？
[主播] 香圣五香鸡。
[主播] 56块钱两只。
[主播] 一只600克。
[主播] 想吃的右下角自己去拍啊。
[主播] 没事没事，我不吃，我要吃我可能会咳嗽。
[主播] 我今天嗓子有点难受。
[主播] 不影响大家。
[主播] 然后还有这个香菇啊，庆元香菇。
[主播] 庆元香菇的品质比较好。
[主播] 我之前去年买过一次。
[主播] 水泡一下，然后你可以去炖汤啊。
[主播] 或者你去炒其实也可以啊。
[主播] 董老师怎么不说英语的？OK, if you want English, sure, sure。
[主播] 想要什么英语？
[主播] 我们说喝的酒啊。
[主播] 是烧鸡，烧鸡叫 roast chicken。
[主播] I believe so。
[主播] Roast chicken。
[主播] C H I C K E N。
[主播] And also you need some wine。
[主播] 喝的酒啊。
[主播] 这个叫烧鸡，喝的酒一般有什么酒呢？
[主播] 是酒不分家，对吧？
[主播] 你真的一提到酒，那就提到了整个中国历史的文人精神史啊。
[主播] 哪个喝酒的人不写诗，哪个写诗的人不喝酒？
[主播] 呃，关于酒啊，我们平常其实喝的。
[主播] 现在应该叫做我们所喝的应该叫 spirit。
[主播] Spirit。
[主播] 什么意思？ Spirit大家以前学过有精神。
[主播] 人的灵魂的意思。
[主播] 它其实就是特别高度的酒，特别高浓度的酒。
[主播] 就是喝完之后可能你会很很那个什么，很晕乎的这种。
[主播] 或者叫 liquor。
[主播] liquor,也叫做这个酒。
[主播] 然后我们平常所说的这个 wine呢， wine其实大部分就指的是红酒的意思啊。
[主播] Usually speaking。
[主播] 我们所喝的那个其实应该叫 spirit,因为它的度数太高了。
[主播] OK。
[主播] 然后当然你所喝的啤酒叫 beer。
[主播] 当然酒也可以叫 alcohol,对吧？
[主播] 只要含有酒精的都可以叫 alcohol。
[主播] Wine一般就是就是葡萄酒或者就是红酒的意思啊。
[主播] 好，这个是关于这你想知道的一些英语东西啊。
[主播] Roast chicken。
[主播] liquor, spirit。
[主播] And also you can say alcohol。
[主播] 反差，我需要反差，谢谢啊。
[主播] 好，这个香菇是吧？
[主播] 来下一个牛排啊。
[主播] 古斯，原切，美国精选。
[主播] 精选安格斯古斯牛。
[主播] 安格斯是一个什么？安格斯其实是一个牛的品种。
[主播] 大家知道现在在世界范围内关于我们一般吃的比较贵一点的牛，第一个是安格斯牛。
[主播] 安格斯牛其实最发现于苏格兰，然后后来它的品种推广到了全球很多的地方。
[主播] 还有一个当然知道，比如说像日本的和牛，对吧？
[主播] 然后呢，他们因为大量的其实让牛吃的是粮食，所以牛是比较比较肥的。
[主播] 因为比较肥，所以它才能那种肥瘦相见那种雪花纹路。
[主播] 所以一般雪花纹路的肉呢，其实就是牛牛要比较肥。
[主播] 它要得跑开外面很厚很厚的脂肪才行。
[主播] 通常情况下，大家养的牛是不可能到那种程度的。
[主播] 然后呢，安格斯牛在全国各地都有。
[主播] 但是如果说是日本的和牛，直到现在他们是禁止出口的。
[主播] 所以很多时候你在其他地方听到的和牛，其实他拿买的日本和牛那个那个精子，然后跟这个安格斯牛去交配，这是第一代。
[主播] 这时候可能是50%的这个和牛，然后再交配，75%再交配。
[主播] 就是它这样一直这样去做，但它没有做到完全00%。
[主播] 因为他们现在不允许这个出口。
[主播] 呃，这就提到了这个安格斯牛和这个日本的和牛。
[主播] 当然我们也有特别好的牛，对吧？
[主播] 安格斯出肉率高。
[主播] 可能有很多更懂的朋友啊。
[主播] 我只是在想看到了这个安格斯和和牛，我突然想到了其实。
[主播] 大家现在吃的很多东西背后都是农业长期的投入，我相信这一两年大家随著这个社会的发展和经济的发展。
[主播] 我们对于生活品质要求越来越高的时候，大家后来会关注很多事情。
[主播] 有生活中很多小的细节，就是。
[主播] 为什么我们说这个其实未来这一代人他使命非常多。
[主播] 比如说大家知道像我们吃的猪肉，现在养的小白猪的猪种。
[主播] 它是其实需要进口的，或者是猪的那个精子它需要进口的。
[主播] 就是它是很贵的。
[主播] 它就像芯片一样。
[主播] 它也是需要比较长时间的投入的。
[主播] 再比如说大家喝的酸奶，其实酸奶里头那个发酵的那个菌。
[主播] 那个菌也是进口的。
[主播] 就是那里头，所以大家真正的如果走到农业里头，你会发现农业里头我们要做的投入。
[主播] 研发和付出太多了。
[主播] 大家以为农业只是简单的耕种。
[主播] 其实不是。
[主播] 现在农业需要背后有非常大的这个长时间的科技的投入。
[主播] 很多的种子，你像我们种的很多的粮食的种子。
[主播] 他卖你的种子你第一代种是可以的，但如果你拿收的种子再种第二代，它迅速就会减产或者病虫害就出来了。
[主播] 所以农业必须是需要一些高科技的投入，也需要一些高学历人才的投入。
[主播] 农业也需要一些相对有力量的企业去长期的研发。
[主播] 这个背后的有时候真的都时间都不是一两年能看到的。
[主播] 都不是一两年。
[主播] 所以前一段时间有一个话题特别热嘛，说关于芯片和高科技。
[主播] 因为那些非常的直接，大家能看到。
[主播] 但其实大家也有时候可能有的人不太了解农业背后其实也有更大的科技在投入。
[主播] 这就是为什么以前虽然我做一个英语老师，但是我总喜欢给孩子们这个胡说八道，好为人师呢？
[主播] 我我看到了什么，我就去了解。
[主播] 我了解完了，我甚至会问一些我认识的相关领域的人。
[主播] 我真正问完了之后，我也会在课堂上给孩子们说。
[主播] 有的孩子他从小就对星辰大海充满兴趣。
[主播] 有的孩子就对五谷杂粮充满兴趣。
[主播] 有的孩子对诗词歌赋充满兴趣，有的孩子对绘画雕塑充满兴趣。
[主播] 你要让他们在小的时候对每一个领域发现自己的兴趣，然后他们就会有这个决心。
[主播] 也有信心长时间的投入。
[主播] 如果说未来社会要更好的话。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 是我们自己的桃花园。
[主播] 理想国大同社会。
[主播] 那一定在很多方面都是需要技术的发展的。
[主播] 这个是必须的。
[主播] 当然这个牛排大家不用吃的想那么多，只是个实惠和好吃而已啊。
[主播] 而且大家也知道在农业方面的投入，有的时候经常面临一个问题是什么？
[主播] 就是。
[主播] 周期非常长。
[主播] 你不像科技产品，我这次造出来了，立刻我就进行路测。
[主播] 测完了之后，比如说汽车对吧，路测完就可以立刻开始。
[主播] 但农业你得种。
[主播] 比如说大家知道为什么我们都特别喜欢袁隆平老爷，为什么说他很伟大呢？
[主播] 他就在到田里头。
[主播] 你知道很多，我以前有学生上这个西北农林大学。
[主播] 我曾经给他们这课堂上讲过，后来就有孩子报了西北农林大学。
[主播] 然后孩子大学四年在学校里养蚕，养猪。
[主播] 学校院子里养蚕养猪。
[主播] 还跟我发了视频，经常都是猪跑了。
[主播] 老师给他打电话。
[主播] 中午一身汗。
[主播] 在学校院子里。
[主播] 在学校院子里养蚕养猪。
[主播] 还跟我发的视频经常都是猪跑的。
[主播] 老给他打电话。
[主播] 中午一身汗。
[主播] 在学校院子追猪跑。
[主播] 听著很搞笑对吧？
[主播] 如果是不懂的家长有时候可能会说，我供你读了这么多年书，你去学校追猪。
[主播] 但是大家要知道农业背后其实就是这种，就是你得尊重世界和自然的规律。
[主播] 庄稼不可能三天熟。
[主播] 机器可能三天造出来，但庄稼真的不可能三天熟。
[主播] 它就是需要那么长的时间，然后你再去不断的去杂交，去改良种子。
[主播] 它需要的就是耐心。
[主播] 所以越是这种极其需要耐心和时间的东西，反而越难以攻克。
[主播] 因为它需要的技术成本的投入和人力和资源，时间投入太高了。
[主播] 太高太高了。
[主播] 所以有的时候你需要去理解，你理解了可能才会尊重。
[主播] 因为坦诚来说，现在很多的农学招生是很困难的。
[主播] 很困难的。
[主播] 因为大家可能都觉得这个太接地气了，太土了。
[主播] 大家不想去。
[主播] 我把一个孩子交了那么多年，他考试成绩那么好，结果读那么多年书去学校里追猪。
[主播] 很正常。
[主播] 我以前认识我们单位一个同事，他丈夫在西边农林是养蚕的。
[主播] 养了博士了。
[主播] 养蚕，这么多年一直在养蚕。
[主播] 他丈夫每天爱蚕比爱他的时间都，就是跟蚕相处的时间比他相处的时间都多。
[主播] 你不能理解那种人在那方面的投入。
[主播] 当我们不能理解的时候，其实我们学会一个最起码的尊重。
[主播] 因为不要小看这些。
[主播] 有一天你要吃的安全，吃的健康，还想吃的实惠。
[主播] 背后其实就是那些人在阳光下追著猪，在暴雨天的时候抱回了一捆蚕桑叶。
[主播] 这个背后的时间投入是漫长的。
[主播] 是真的漫长的。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我小时候就养过蚕。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 小时候我就喜欢那种东西。
[主播] 我记得我养蚕，但是我又上初中去学校了，我没有时间管。
[主播] 那蚕越养越多，因为它会那个，那个蚕蛾会生子嘛，用一张纸，它生在纸上。
[主播] 每年到春天，它得有一定恒温才能出来，给上面稍微撒一点点水，把它放在我的衣服口袋里头。
[主播] 用我的体温，它不是恒温的嘛。
[主播] 蚕纸过几天就破壳而出。
[主播] 破壳而出呢，一开始很小的黑色的，身上还有绒毛的虫。
[主播] 那个时候呢，桑叶必须得嫩，嫩芽尖才行。
[主播] 我继续踩这个尖，清明前后。
[主播] 桑叶就长出来了。
[主播] 然后呢，养著养著，基本上每年到收小麦的时候，它就已经结茧了，黄色的，白色的，甚至还有浅粉色的。
[主播] 就那时候拿一个大的扫帚，它自己爬上去，它找一个合适的位置，它就一直吐丝吐丝吐丝，所以小时候被那个春蚕到死丝方尽，蜡炬成灰泪始干。
[主播] 我在想我以后有儿子，我一定让他小时候养蚕。
[主播] 对，就是让他让他接触这些，就是让他体会这种陪伴一个生命成长，然后看著他最后长大的样子。
[主播] 这这是很浪漫的。
[主播] 当然我之后去上学了，因为那个蚕没人管的，那蚕越种，越养越多，越养越多，多到之后我妈害怕。
[主播] 我妈害怕哪个呢？
[主播] 我妈见他就跑就。
[主播] 之后实在没有办法，我爸又没在家，我之后托付给隔壁的朋友，隔壁朋友弄了两天都不下去了。
[主播] 我之后托付给我，我我二爸，我二叔。
[主播] 他每天就骑著摩托车，在那个别人家的家长都是忙著挣钱，给孩子买东西，我们家的这个家长就经常帮著孩子去附近山沟沟里，然后呢，或者是一个悬崖边找一颗大的桑树，然后找到了之后就摘很多的叶子，背上一大包回来倒里头。
[主播] 你倒里头你那个蚕特别多的时候，你站在旁边甚至能听到那个湿桑叶沙沙的声音的。
[主播] 它甚至能吃出那种声音。
[主播] 然后一会会那个桑叶就全部吃完了。
[主播] 一会就全部吃完了。
[主播] 所以，我刚讲这个，我小时候养蚕的过程，其实当然我那个不是搞科技啊，我那个跟科技也没有任何关系，纯粹是个人兴趣。
[主播] 我只是看到了刚才这个牛排，我突然想到了在农业背后，比如说在动物的品种。
[主播] 在粮食的这个种子。
[主播] 在甚至很多长期要投入的科技和人力方面。
[主播] 我特别害怕家长们都只渴望孩子去做那些看著光鲜亮丽的金融，让孩子做那些看起来很高级的管理，但其实你发现孩子之后毕业了，也管不了人，对吧？
[主播] 也管不了人。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 反而这个这个旁边这个孩子听著听著嫉妒了。
[嘉宾] 有感悟了。
[主播] 想要开始进行演讲了，孩子说主要是做农业怎么样。
[主播] 所以有的时候你在农产品方面绝对的追求低价，其实不一定合理。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 它会伤害产业链上的每一个人。
[主播] 想要碰自己去拍啊。
[主播] 所以我说这段其实的目的啥，我说这段目的其实是想鼓，想鼓励屏幕前，因为我知道这两天屏幕前有很多的家长，就让孩子在听。
[主播] 如果孩子你小时候真的对这些充满了，充满了兴趣，你就沿著这个路一路走下去。
[主播] 你只要长期投入，我相信你会有好的结果的。
[主播] 对吧？
[嘉宾] 牛排还没有了。
[主播] 牛排卖空了。
[主播] 但我在讲的是蚕。
[主播] 我讲的是蚕。
[嘉宾] 通过牛排想到蚕。
[主播] 我觉得每一个领域都可以做出非常好的结果，只要你怀著使命感和勇气。
[主播] 数十年如一日的长期修炼与坚持。
[主播] 每一个领域都需要人才的投入。
[主播] 农业才是第一产业啊。
[主播] 大家的饭碗必须要紧紧的端在自己手里。
[主播] 那这个过程中像育种，对吧，像很多科技投入，你像我刚才小到这个酸奶里头的菌种。
[主播] 我们之前都得进口。
[主播] 好一点的菌种真的是进口的。
[主播] 可能很多人都不知道，对吧，反常识，甚至你平常买那个小猪仔。
[主播] 它英国猪或者美国猪，它是需要进口的。
[主播] 大家不爱惜。
[主播] 所以我们希望让更多的孩子去关注农业。
[主播] 要不然我们特别不想以后提到农业，好像只能是悲情的站在田间地头里，看著脸上全是皱纹，然后愁容满面的老爷爷老奶奶，然后呢东西滞销了，能不能帮帮他们？
[主播] 我们更希望是一群年轻人，朝气蓬勃，精力充沛，然后呢在社会各界的关注下，在他们家人的支持下，然后他们投身农业之后改良品种。
[主播] 比如说这个东西果子更好吃了。
[主播] 它就更容易卖出去。
[主播] 它不仅能够让我们欢迎，它甚至能够出口到世界各地。
[主播] 我们有一天能够很自豪的把自己农产品介绍给身边每一个人，甚至介绍给世界上的每一个人。
[主播] 但是大家要知道这个理想画面不是你坐著等来的。
[主播] 你得去坚持去做。
[主播] 你在这个做的过程中，你一定会受很多的委屈。
[主播] 或者说非常多的委屈。
[主播] 你可能会挨很多的骂，你可能会有很多的失败。
[主播] 我当咱那个袁隆平先生的那个传记，能找那个不？
[嘉宾] 看看有没有。
[主播] 找一下那本书。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 我以前读过那本书，就是因为那段时间大家都很难过嘛，他离开了我们。
[主播] 然后当时我就在读那本书，我当时还给班里学生讲了那个，我让当时的班里学生去读他的书。
[主播] 他就讲到他为了守著那些苗是多么的难。
[主播] 他的苗被那些人破坏。
[主播] 然后呢，他一个人每天在地里头。
[主播] 夏天那么热，蒸的那个暑气，其实很容易让人难受。
[主播] 但是你要对此有热情，你就会长期的投入。
[主播] 我有理由相信今天我所说的刚才这一段，对吧，可能语言混乱，逻辑也不是那么清晰的，这个话，可能会感触到屏幕前一些家长或者一些孩子。
[主播] 我也有理由相信可能会有人去自己去选择，去选择做农业。
[主播] 如果这是你的兴趣就行。
[主播] 当然我也知道，比如说在这个从业者中，可能大家会考虑到很多的现实的收入什么什么的问题。
[主播] 所以我说你应该去钻研一些比较比较精尖的东西。
[主播] 就是每一个领域你只要做到特别靠前，其实都可以照顾好自己的，同时你也可以为社会出力，你觉得呢？
[主播] 大虾，这个虾。
[主播] 厄瓜多尔，这些年我们买厄瓜多尔的虾多一些，因为它确实便宜，实惠，而且虾比较好，个头大。
[主播] 我可能只是刚才提到了安格斯牛的品种，然后突然有感而发。
[主播] 对不起啊。
[主播] 我说了一段废话。
[主播] 我卖虾卖虾。
[主播] 厄瓜多尔的大白虾，产自秘鲁渔场。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我刚说那个方面是真的。
[主播] 就是我时常在思考为什么，为什么好像最后我们的农业发展是不是只能靠悲情？
[主播] 是不是只能靠那些田间地头滞销的老爷爷老奶奶，然后让大家在这个同情和怜悯中去购买他们的东西？
[主播] 然后买到了万一有一两个果子确实很酸，然后呢，我们也只能说算了算了，我愿意理解他，我愿意支持他。
[主播] 那不是最终结果。
[主播] 一定不是。
[主播] 那个走不长远的。
[主播] 你相信吗？
[主播] 它走不长远的。
[主播] 它一定是因为科技和人才的投入，让这个果子好吃，甚至它有了很多新的样子，新的口感。
[主播] 而且它价格，还有包括物流和售后体系做的更好，它一定得有一些商业手段。
[主播] 但是你坚持住农出心。
[主播] 如果说你只是想让农民挣钱，其实最后农民是挣不了钱的。
[主播] 这就是理想主义者和现实世界之间的差距。
[主播] 我在想如果是更多的技术和人才投入之后，让这个我们以后看到农业不全是在田间地头苦苦劳作，浑身疾病，然后愁容满面的老爷爷老奶奶，反而是一群这个生龙活虎，然后呢，充满活力，然后技术和研发都很先进一些年轻人。
[主播] 就是他们投身到这个行业里头才更好。
[主播] 我我觉得每个人应该去探索自己的兴趣，我相信肯定屏幕前有很多人跟我一样，一提到农业就满含热泪。
[主播] 然后心生欢喜的人。
[主播] Facebook之前有个工程师说，这个时代聪明的年轻人只想著让大家去点击广告。
[主播] 这真的太糟糕了。
[主播] 很真实对吗？
[主播] 很真实。
[主播] 我们呼吁其实大家去发现孩子更多的兴趣，有的孩子他就是在田间地头更开心。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 我清楚的记得我们班原来初中有个孩子，那孩子学习特别差。
[主播] 跟我关系还很好。
[主播] 第一个他跑不好，第二个他劳动积极，第三个他就喜欢干活。
[主播] 然后毕业之后呢，他就后来就自己一直在忙东忙西，然后他现在我们当地的这个农业局在工作。
[主播] 他就是每天跟农民白白们在一起，种一点这，种一点那。
[主播] 他也很快心。
[主播] 而且我觉得他的价值，社会价值应该比我的社会价值要大。
[主播] 因为他是真的直接帮助了一些具体的人。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 我可能只是在当年教书的时候，我帮助了一些学生。
[主播] 我我是真真诚的觉得他比我的社会价值更大。
[主播] 是起力活。
[主播] 但是你知道有的人他喜欢这种的，有的人就喜欢放松的在田间地头。
[主播] 自由的奔走。
[主播] 他就喜欢看著那个花开花。
[主播] 他就有耐心等著树发芽开花结果。
[主播] 你知道看著树冒芽，开花结果，那个过程本身就充满喜悦嘛。
[主播] 像陪著一个孩子长大一样。
[主播] 你知道他要去施肥，要去浇水，要去除草。
[主播] 他本身就是一种智慧和耐心。
[主播] 人是在这个农业劳作中才能获得快乐的。
[主播] 我给你举个例子啊。
[主播] 一个非常伟大的作家，还写过是一个俄国人，还写过忏悔录。
[主播] 托尔斯泰。
[主播] 忏悔录一共三本嘛，奥古斯丁写过一个，然后呢，这个卢梭写过一个，然后呢，托尔斯泰写过一个。
[主播] 托尔斯泰呢，他是一个贵族。
[主播] 他有很多的土地。
[主播] 他的早期，他也参过军对吧，他的早期呢，其实就是那些农奴们在他的田地劳作养活了他。
[主播] 他以前其实是感觉到自己，早期他对自己的人生理解没有那么深刻，但是他到了晚年之后，他就更加的痛苦。
[主播] 他就一直很痛苦，他的痛苦觉得他一方面发现了社会的悲惨，他一方面又在给别人制造生活的悲惨，他觉得他在利用别人劳动价值，所以他因此感到难受。
[主播] 托尔斯泰是一个极其清醒的人。
[主播] 我特别喜欢托尔斯泰，我觉得这才是真正的人间清醒。
[主播] 托尔斯泰后来就，他也开始下地干活了。
[主播] 他就下地干活。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 他在他晚年的作品中，他明确的表达了真正的参加了农业劳作之后，他由内而外感受到的快乐。
[主播] 对不起，我卖虾啊。
[主播] 厄瓜多尔的白虾。
[主播] 这个是多大的呢？
[嘉宾] 3040。
[主播] 有2030的没今天？
[嘉宾] 有。
[嘉宾] 给他。
[主播] 2030的个头更大，虾肉更多一些。
[主播] 当然它价格也更高，因为它生长时间长了才能大。
[主播] 3040大概就这么大，它个头相对小一点。
[主播] 但是虾的营养和口感没有什么区别。
[主播] 因为都是秘鲁渔场，厄瓜多尔南太平洋附近。
[主播] 然后呢，因为那一片都是第一个农业国家，第二个大家知道靠著太平洋这边的从北美到南美，其实有一个非常完整的很高的山系。
[主播] 所以水一般不会流到这边来，所以相对来说他们的海域能干净一些。
[主播] 所以很多人在给孩子去买东西的时候，非常重视这一点。
[主播] 虾，三斤对吧？
[主播] 多少钱？
[嘉宾] 三斤三两109。
[主播] 还有三斤三两。
[嘉宾] 139。
[嘉宾] 那个是2030。
[主播] 只是大小的区别。
[主播] 这个虾是捞出来之后迅速冷冻了。
[主播] Quickly frozen.
[主播] Frozen。
[主播] Quickly frozen。
[主播] 就迅速冷冻了，Freeze叫结冰的意思。
[主播] Freeze除了结冰还有什么？还有站住。
[主播] 就西游记里头孙悟空定，那个定的意思。
[主播] 比如说我们小时候玩过那个冰棍，小话，你们玩过没有？
[主播] 我跑著跑著你追我，我冰棍，我不动了，你就说你不能动我了。
[主播] 然后我看你走了，我悄悄我继续跑。
[嘉宾] 那叫三不人吧。
[主播] 哎呀呀，看，看，有的地方叫木头人。
[主播] 就是如果我还在跑的时候你抓住我，那这时候就该我抓你们了。
[主播] 就比如说我定住了。
[主播] Freeze, it's like freeze.
[主播] 快话点说，定。
[主播] Freeze。
[主播] Freeze就是人不动的意思。
[主播] Freeze,OK。
[主播] 它可以有结冰，也可以有人不动的意思啊。
[主播] Frozen就是冰冻的。
[主播] Quickly frozen in ice。
[主播] 它迅速的冻在冰里头。
[主播] 大概这个感觉。
[主播] 这个虾呢，你看呢，它收到之后外面其实是包著一层薄薄的冰衣，包著，大家学过coat就是外套嘛，对吧，像人穿著外套一样。
[主播] 穿著一层冰衣。
[主播] Coated in很薄的叫thin,coated in thin ice。
[主播] 它本来是ice,这个N和N和I连接的，thin ice,OK。
[主播] Coated in thin ice。
[主播] 然后呢，包著一层薄薄的冰衣。
[主播] 虾为什么要包冰衣呢？大家知道虾包冰衣之后，它就能锁住鲜。
[主播] 它口感不会变，它也不会太干。
[主播] 因为虾在死了之后，身体会分解一种酶，它会自己溶解自己的肉。
[主播] 它为了不让你吃，它会自己溶解自己的肉。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 所以一般虾都要包一点点这个薄薄的冰衣。
[主播] 这是一个基本知识。
[主播] 有的人说买虾里头怎么有水？
[主播] 这个三斤三两是净虾的含量，对吧？
[主播] 加上这里头的冰应该是更重的。
[主播] 必须得有这个冰衣，如果没有冰衣的话，这个口感可能会糟糕，它可能会变干。
[主播] 或者有的人里头会加点保水剂，其实保水剂现在也是一个已经证明确实可能没有太大对人身体伤害的一个东西啊。
[主播] 大家要理性，如果你在农业或者你在食品加工行业，你知道的东西做过多的时候。
[主播] 大家就不会妖魔化这个食品添加剂，但是我们也绝对不是鼓吹食品添加剂。
[主播] 就是你用科学理性的态度，你知道有的是可以的。
[主播] 而且在药理学里头有句话嘛，对有句话，不谈剂量谈效果，那就是耍流氓。
[主播] 有的人呢，大家可能因为不知道，然后就被一些经常会误导，说那个对人体有害，它可能得吃一大桶才能有害。
[主播] 但是你吃那么多可能小的根本不足道，嗯。
[主播] 这是一个背景知识啊，背景知识。
[主播] 有朋友问，有朋友还在问，说所以李白到底是不是刺客？
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 我们有李白传在三号链接。
[主播] 孩子把手机放下听话。
[主播] 三号链接李白传买一下，买完了之后回去看书，听话行不行？
[主播] 少打一点游戏。
[嘉宾] 行。
[主播] 行不行？
[主播] 当然我的观点也不一定对啊，我观点不一定对。
[主播] 可能我只是这么多年一个苦行僧式的这个生活习惯，我习惯了而已。
[主播] 我以前在班里给学生教书的时候，其实我曾经是拒绝他们去打游戏的。
[主播] 我也经常会给他们说，我说现实世界里有那么多的好，爬一爬山，打一打羽毛球，锻炼锻炼身体，见几个朋友，读一两本书。
[主播] 实在不行，你到大学你谈个恋爱都行。
[主播] 我这有可能是错的，对吧，一代人与一代人娱乐的方式，我不可能，我不应该把自己偏颇错误的这个陈腐的观念强加在孩子身上。
[主播] 当然也有很多孩子受影响。
[主播] 我很开心，我觉得我很开心。
[主播] 来，现在给大家推荐的是意面啊。
[主播] 这个100零几？
[嘉宾] 109。
[主播] 109啊。
[主播] 109到手六盒。
[主播] 然后这两天也有很多朋友说是因为在各种社交媒体上看到了我前几天卖大米那种随口张口就来小作文，或者是我讲到我很多的人生故事。
[主播] 然后呢，很多人现在可能就同意我的观点。
[主播] 说就是比如说书读的多了，你觉得是有用的。
[主播] 我特别感动一个就是董宇辉，我以前觉得读书没有用，这两天我听完在你们直播间听完之后，我看到了顿顿讲的诗词。
[主播] 我看到了悠悠他脱口而出标准发音，我看到了七七他所见证的事情。
[主播] 很多人说突然觉得读书是有用的。
[主播] 当然这个完全是一个抬举啊，我们读书一直都有用。
[主播] 读书一直都有用。
[主播] 如果你觉得读书没有用，可能是你身边人书都没有读好而已。
[主播] 你没有接触到那种真正把书读成了的人，他们对于社会有多么大的贡献。
[主播] 我们只是特别肤浅的这个，或者我自己只是特别肤浅的这个知识从业者，或者教育从业者。
[主播] 但是我觉得如果东方真选的直播间能够唤醒大家对于知识的血，对于阅读的兴趣，我觉得那是我的福气，我很开心。
[主播] 然后有很多人说因为在其他媒体社交软件上看到了我们的视频，然后第一次选择下载了抖音。
[主播] 然后呢，每天在这里就听，可以，很欢迎。
[主播] 但是大家不要把搜身用来听我说。
[主播] 你听别人，你永远都是观众。
[主播] 真的。
[主播] 我真的，我觉得听永远只是观众，但你自己去看，你自己去读，自己去写的时候，你就慢慢变成了主角。
[主播] 这个很重要。
[主播] 所以让孩子听一段时间，如果孩子在直播间里听，会觉得他说的道理，那他买了那些书之后，你就把手机放下，让孩子自己去读书。
[主播] 读完了书之后，你们俩甚至你带著孩子在家里看一看那些历史上的纪录片，看完了之后，你们俩再结合著这一段的历史来去分享这本书中你的感受和他们的感受。
[主播] 不必去问那些权威者们，他们怎么解读的，因为我说了有多少个读者，就有多少个哈姆雷特。
[主播] 只要尊重了基本的历史事实，孩子可以产生自己不同的看法。
[主播] 谁说李白就只能解读出浪漫呢？
[主播] 谁说李白就今天只能按董宇辉所说的解读出勇气呢？
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 那我们可以解读出很多的东西，完全看你自己怎么理解。
[主播] 只要大量的去了解。
[主播] 谁说李白就今天只能按董宇辉所说的解读出勇气呢？
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 那我们可以解读出很多的东西，完全看你自己怎么理解，只要大量的去了解事实，在了解事实的基础上去进行的各种的理性感性的发挥，我认为都合理。
[主播] 所以这可能是一个当老师的职业毛病啊，总喜欢在屏幕前絮絮叨叨，啰啰嗦嗦。
[主播] 但是我特别害怕大家就是又把所有的时间从原来的游戏，从原来虚拟的东西最后全部转成了，比如说在这里听董宇辉絮叨。
[主播] 其实董宇辉絮叨的也并不对。
[主播] 董宇辉经常会说错。
[主播] 董宇辉前两天讲苏东坡的时候，然后一直脑子里想着杜甫。
[主播] 还有人把那个视频发给我，对吧？
[主播] 还有人董宇辉你写scattered stars，少写了一个E。
[主播] 他们给我截图，发现确实是对的。
[主播] 我感谢他，我说感谢你提醒。
[主播] 看上一段时间就让孩子回归现实世界里，看一看书，好吗？
[主播] 就像我，就像我当时在这个当年的先先的方方，资助那个孩子一样。
[主播] 那个孩子后来考上大学之后，他一开始给我发消息，后来我说孩子你不要给我发消息了。
[主播] 你你未来是要去看更多的风景，去遇见更多有趣的人，然后呢，你要成为自己。
[主播] 我只是陪伴你走一段路的人。
[主播] 我不应该一直陪在你身边。
[主播] 如果你一直跟在我身边，说明你没有长进。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 你应该像小鸟离开鸟巢一样。
[主播] 那样离开我。
[主播] 所以那个孩子后来，我觉得他的状态就很好。
[主播] 如果一个老师总希望孩子一直留在自己身边，那是一种自私。
[主播] 这种观点我反正我觉得我是这么想的。
[主播] 去年我们在一开始带货的时候，有一个媒体还采访过我，说董老师你不是教过50万学生吗？
[主播] 那你直播的时候随便叫上5万人，其实直播间应该人很多了。
[主播] 所以大能里为什么有时候直播间三四十万人，我觉得其实很正常。
[主播] 你光我自己的学生，真的有50万。
[主播] 我说我从来不会允许我的学生来。
[主播] 有一次我记得我们一开始在直播的时候，那会直播间里十几个，折腾一晚上9块9的东西卖不出去的时候，当时真的很灰心丧气。
[主播] 我甚至都动过那样的邪念。
[主播] 然后就是说让学生来听。
[主播] 但是有一天我正在直播，直播间有个学生说，董老帅，董老帅。
[主播] 我不是董老师吗？
[主播] 老师吗？
[主播] 我说去掉那一横，把我叫董老帅。
[主播] 自恋嘛。
[主播] 骗学生我是中关村朱建伦。
[主播] 虽然他们也不信。
[主播] 然后有一天我正在直播，我看到屏幕有个董老帅，我当时瞬间就感觉很后悔。
[主播] 我说我知道屏幕前，你在这里，孩子手机放下，现在跟我写作业去，现在跟我读书去，现在出去打羽毛球去，现在跟我睡觉去，实在不行你跟我谈个恋爱去。
[主播] 你记得吧？
[主播] 当时应该是我跟你打，还是我跟石明在打？
[主播] 我忘了。
[主播] 咱俩打。
[主播] 我当时那天我就很生气，我突然觉得我在屏幕前失态了。
[主播] 后来我就在我所有以前的那些学生的群里，和我发朋友圈里就提醒孩子，我说你以后不要来听了。
[主播] 你那么小，你的时间和精力不应该在我这。
[主播] 如果我因为要挣那一点小钱，我就让你来听我的直播，你长大之后会恨我的。
[主播] 你会长大的，对吗？
[主播] 你长大之后一定会恨我的。
[主播] 你会想当年遇见个什么东西。
[主播] 所以我一直拒绝，我一直拒绝学生来听我的直播。
[主播] 偶尔搭听了一点点有趣的知识就行了，但是更多时候其实是应该让孩子自己去读书的。
[主播] 然后呢，我后来又跟他们说，如果你爸妈需要买一点菜，对吧？
[主播] 爸妈需要买点菜你可以来，但请你自己不要来。
[主播] 也不要整天在我这讲听。
[主播] 我其实讲的也并不深入，也并不完整。
[主播] 可能甚至有时是一种泛知识。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 是极其夹杂着极其强烈的个人情感的知识。
[主播] 我也特别希望有一天你拿着杜甫传，拿着苏东坡传，拿着李白传，可以解读出极其具有自己强烈的一个。
[主播] 但你要知道董宇辉可不是一直在镜头前，在这直播把那知识播出来的。
[主播] 董宇辉是在漫长的失眠的夜里头，实在睡不着觉，洗完了衣服，拖完了地，实在没事干，坐在这去看纪录片，研究史料研究出来的。
[主播] 如果没有那些时间，我长期的阅读和修炼，我不可能现在在屏幕前给你啰啰嗦嗦的胡说八道。
[主播] 有的确实是胡说八道。
[主播] 不一定对。
[主播] 所以我知道屏幕前有孩子。
[主播] 所以我必须今天把这段话说给你。
[主播] 我也不知道为什么刚才就从一个牛的品种说到了农业。
[主播] 说到了年轻人应该去寻找自己的使命。
[主播] 说到年轻人要修炼自己。
[主播] 说到年轻人不应该把自己时间沉迷在这些虚拟的东西中。
[主播] 这就是一个老师的毛病。
[主播] 总是喜欢跟人讲道理，毛病。
[主播] 有时候我都烦自己，但是忍不住嘛。
[主播] 我是真的忍不住。
[主播] 为什么这两天我在直播间里不太讲其他的东西了，不太讲废话了？
[主播] 因为真的有老师把我的这个直播直接投屏在他们班的教室黑板上。
[主播] 还给我们发了好几段视频。
[主播] 而且不止一个老师，我至少收到了三四十个老师。
[主播] 所以我这两天尽量很收敛自己。
[主播] 我我其实是一个很糟糕的人，毛病很多，弱点很多，时常脆弱，怯懦，犹豫。
[主播] 但是因为我一旦想到镜头前现在如果有孩子的话，我就必须我得是一个老师的样子。
[主播] 我之前跟大家回忆过，对吧？
[主播] 以前我在当老师的时候。
[主播] 这个可能我在教室外面还跟别人打电话吵了一个架。
[主播] 可能还有家里不好的事情，我很担心。
[主播] 然后可能还有这个要马上要还的贷款还不上。
[主播] 反正我可能有很多种这个令人糟心的事情。
[主播] 对，但我走上讲台那一刻，我必须是一个好的状态。
[主播] 我必须穿着要整齐。
[主播] 我必须要清楚而高效的跟他们讲完知识。
[主播] 然后我也必须要传递出一些正确的理性的价值观。
[主播] 所以很多时候上课之前做俯卧撑。
[主播] 对，我上课之前，包括上播之前为啥做俯卧撑？
[主播] 因为我可能没睡好，太瞌睡了。
[主播] 我害怕我精神不好。
[主播] 所以我就做俯卧撑。
[主播] 我记得我以前在先学啊。
[主播] 我不知道。
[主播] 现在应该没有。
[主播] 我以前在先学校的同事们可能知道。
[主播] 我那会上课，暑假有时候一天上10到12个小时。
[主播] 最后真的扛不住。
[主播] 真的扛不住。
[主播] 体力，因为我比较瘦嘛，体力比较差。
[主播] 头也太大，身体扛不住头。
[主播] 所以那会上课经常就上着上着没有力气，怎么办？
[主播] 学生们去做题，我就跑到教室后面连续做30个俯卧撑，我瞬间发现，哇，我还可以再讲一会。
[主播] 我就继续讲。
[主播] 然后过一会不行，我又去30个俯卧撑。
[主播] 结果我平时在办公室里也是，我只要困了我就做30个俯卧撑。
[主播] 让自己清醒清醒。
[主播] 我跟董董人，董董昨天前天还把那个发到了这个抖音上。
[主播] 就是就是一直做俯卧撑。
[主播] 我记得当时一个夏天下来，你感觉自己收获特别满，很幸福。
[主播] 就你既练了一身肌肉，还交了很多的学生。
[主播] 不不不，不说废话。
[主播] 这个意大利面，意大利面。
[主播] 经典番茄肉酱烩意大利面。
[主播] 这个有几个啊，导演？
[主播] 这个是六盒。
[主播] 109到。
[主播] 109六盒。
[主播] 六盒，应该是这三个口味各两盒，对吧？
[嘉宾] 我们有不同规格。
[主播] 不同规格。
[主播] 大家可以自己选啊。
[主播] 你们在我们这就可以像逛超市一样，行不行？
[主播] 对不起，我我不是一个靠谱的售货员，我可能是拉着你唠家常那个，但是我给你介绍不清楚产品，对不起。
[主播] 我会进步的。
[主播] 你可以点开链接到里头看一看自己有喜欢的那些味道，你可以选六盒109。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 其实我屏幕前，我我面前应该是有个说这个产品，它的品牌叫空果意大利，日常价204，直播价109。
[主播] 保质期九个月，快递是申通中通。
[主播] 规格是六盒，一盒270克。
[主播] 是国内首创的素食意大利面。
[主播] 我我面前其实正常情况是有一个这个的，但因为最近我在这胡扯，导演也不跟我反馈了。
[主播] 我也不看。
[主播] 我有时候也给大家介绍不清楚，你再看一下。
[主播] 肉酱包肉多料足。
[主播] 配齐海盐橄榄油黑胡椒碎，还有帕马森芝士欧芹。
[主播] Yes, yes。
[主播] 开锅煮15分钟，控水后倒出酱包酱酱包再翻炒成出。
[主播] 呀。
[主播] 精选原产地的杜兰小麦。
[主播] 嗯，嗯哼。
[主播] OK。
[主播] 就是平常是有那个信息，但最近一段时间导演不给我反评，因为我每天也不读呢。
[主播] 我在这胡写小作文，胡讲人生经历。
[主播] 导演生气了。
[主播] 想要的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 我会进步的，这两天有很多朋友私信已经提醒了，董宇辉你是个卖货主播，请你做好自己的工作职责。
[主播] 我觉得很庆幸就是生活中一些经历，有一些朋友去提醒你，而不是一味的去赞同你。
[主播] 敢于在你骄傲的时候泼冷水的人。
[主播] 他们往往可能也是真的在关心你啊。
[主播] 功课，想要自己去拍啊。
[主播] 来，接下来一个是这个宁夏的滩羊肉。
[主播] 这个有多少个啊，导演？
[嘉宾] 还有500单。
[主播] 那很快。
[主播] 咱现在直播间里30万人呢。
[主播] 500。
[主播] 宁夏的滩羊。
[主播] 我不知道大家喜欢去西北吗？
[主播] 如果你喜欢去西北啊，你其实从西安出发是非常好的。
[主播] 从西安出发，你晚上可以到，开到或者四个小时。
[主播] 都不用晚上。
[主播] 你可以在这个延安停上一天。
[主播] 然后你去一下宝塔山。
[主播] 其实延安有一个特殊的擀面皮，它是那种黑色粗两做的，很好吃。
[主播] 然后你可以去延安停上一天。
[主播] 然后在延安住一天，第二天再往宁夏去走。
[主播] 到了宁夏呢，大家就知道有一个非常经典的叫叫老毛家还是啥。
[主播] 我记得我去吃过好几次。
[主播] 但我记不住名字。
[主播] 他们就那个手手抓肉。
[主播] 然后泡那个八宝茶。
[主播] 就是把枸杞、红枣、黄色的冰糖，还有茶叶，还有一些芝麻好像。
[主播] 把那个整个泡的那个茶，哇，特别好。
[主播] 我特别喜欢。
[主播] 叫二毛手抓是吧？
[主播] 我忘了叫什么。
[主播] 反正老马手抓。
[主播] 反正我是去过的。
[主播] 所以我记得当时去吃那个手抓肉的时候就特别的畅快。
[主播] 因为那天我是一大早从西安出发。
[主播] 我中间没有停。
[主播] 我开了一路。
[主播] 一路就听着一生所爱嘛。
[主播] 我每次去都一路听一生所爱。
[主播] 然后开了一路。
[主播] 然后饥肠辘辘。
[主播] 到那块之后有一个以前去过的朋友跟我推荐，让我直接去找那家店。
[主播] 我到那家店之后，你就点了一大盘肉，然后泡了个茶。
[主播] 你知道饥肠辘辘的一个女人啊，她需要的就是一顿这个饱餐。
[主播] 然后呢，喝着那个茶，吃着那个肉。
[主播] 那个好像离当地他们的那个钟楼还是鼓楼很近，我记得就在旁边好像是。
[主播] 哇，吃完之后特别舒服。
[主播] 太爽了。
[主播] 这个宁夏的滩羊是因为它在黄河滩上。
[主播] 就是河套平原的西套。
[主播] 它是盐碱地，所以盐碱中和之后，羊肉没有腥膻味。
[主播] 我特别喜欢那个地方。
[主播] 确实有古楼是吧？
[主播] 昨天也有朋友一直在给我提出建议，说董宇辉你不要在直播的时候一直摸鼻子，这样显得对观众不尊重。
[主播] 我对不起啊，我是因为镜头前有强光。
[主播] 照射之后我眼睛和鼻子一直痒。
[主播] 有时候可能是无意识的。
[主播] 我今天尽量控制。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 你可以给大家再放一个一生所爱吗？
[主播] 有朋友要听，可以吗？
[嘉宾] 可以。
[主播] 可以，谢谢啊，谢谢。
[主播] 每次去宁夏的路上，我其实都不怎么说话啊。
[主播] 因为一路在听这个嘛，对吧？
[主播] 就像我跟大家说的，人生其实很多时候讲出来就是很多遗憾。
[主播] 我们那天晚上再给大家讲到这个大话西游的时候，就提到了这个。
[主播] 对不起，对不起。
[主播] 我们那天晚上再给大家讲到这个大话西游的时候，就提到了周星驰年轻时候的遗憾和错过。
[主播] 然后每次去西部。